- [Voiceover] In the figure above,
CDE is an equilateral triangle.
So that means this side
is equal to that side
is equal to that side.
AB and ABCE is a square with an area of 1.
So this is a square with an area of 1.
What is the perimeter of polygon ABCDE?
Well, since we know this
is a square with area 1,
we know that this
is equivalent to that right over there,
and the product of this
number is going to be 1.
So it has to be 1.
This times this is 1.
They're the same thing, so
that is 1, and that is 1.
Well, it's a square, so that
side is also going to be 1.
And this side is also going to be 1.
Now, we were just told that
this is an equilateral triangle.
The length of CD is the
same as DE is the same
as the length of CE.
Well CE has the length 1,
so that has length 1,
and that has length 1.
So what's the perimeter
of the whole polygon?
Well, if we start at A let's just see,
one, two, three, four, five.
It's a five-sided polygon,
all of the sides have the same length,
they're all exactly have a length of 1,
so the perimeter is equal to 5.